finally came home this week
the 53 year old was detained by russian
forces on georgia's de facto border with
its breakaway territory south ossetia
back in 2019
last november gennady was freed after
suffering a stroke
he never recovered
these men paying their respects call
themselves anti-occupation activists
but look at the shoulder badge on the
right a ukrainian georgian composite
flag
they firmly believe that both countries
today share the same enemy russia we
georgians understand what is happening
in ukraine
better than uh anybody else in the world
because what is happening in ukraine
we had in georgia in 2008
back then
president george w bush promised georgia
and ukraine nato membership
later that year russia invaded georgia
to back south ossetian separatists in
their conflict with the tbilisi
government
its forces have never left
the village of horvalletti has been
split in two by the war
local resident luda says detentions
happen all the time
it's scary we're afraid it's really
unpleasant but we're not going to throw
away our homeland our homes where would
we go
the sign up there reads state border of
the republic of south ossetia well south
ossetia is not recognized as a sovereign
country and yet that seems to be
russia's strategy to divide georgia to
keep this conflict unresolved just as
this razor wire divides this village
georgians have been rallying in
solidarity with ukraine
some believe the government isn't
showing kiev enough support for fear of
provoking the kremlin
georgia's governing party calls it
pragmatism
pragmatism means that whenever we can
benefit
from our relations with russian economic
and trade terms we should benefit
however we
should not
and we will never
give up our
national interest which is our
territorial integrity and our western
integration
russian security forces have detained
more than 1
400 georgians since 2008
although most get released with a fine
some like gennady have been jailed
torture and murder have also been
documented
georgia and ukraine share the same fate
unfortunately russia doesn't want
georgia to be free
georgians know all too well the likely
human cost of another war with russia
roman foreign